Business letters are a great way to present your message in a classic, polished style.
In addition to being formal and structured,...
...business letters are also quite versatile...
...as they can be used for official requests, announcements, cover letters and more.
While there are different ways to format your letter,...
...block format is one of the most common.
Block format keeps the text at left justified and single-spaced...
...with double spaces between paragraphs and different sections.
This layout keeps the letter simple and legible.
The first section of a letter is the opening.
As you start your letter, include your mailing address,...
...the full date and the recipient's name, company and address.
When you greet the recipient in the salutation,...
...use "Dear" along with their title and last name.
If you don't know the recipient's title, use their full name instead.
Also, add a colon to the end of your greeting.
In the first paragraph of the body, introduce yourself and your main point.
Following paragraphs should go into the details of your main point,...
...while the final paragraph should restate the letter's purpose...
...and provide a call to action if necessary.
For formal closing, use "Sincerely"...
...or for something more personal try using "Cordially" or "Best regards".
Whatever you choose, end your closing with a comma.
For the signature, skip four lines after your closing...
...and type your name, job title and company name.
If you're submitting a hard copy,...
...sign your name in the empty space using blue or black ink.
And if you're enclosing any documents or items,...
...skip four lines after the signature and list them here.